Speaker 1: Let's go next to Dominic
from Texas. Dominic, you're on the air.
Speaker 5: Hi, David. I had two questions, the
first one is, what do you think is going to happen
to Fox News once Rupert Murdoch is gone?
Speaker 1: I don't know. You know,
I read an interesting long form
piece about six months ago about how
he has multiple kids. I don't remember
which ones, but like, one of them
is very involved with Fox and one of them
wants nothing to do with it. But there's
the idea that the one that's involved might take
it in a different direction. But I don't know. I
don't have any prediction, really. I think it
might change. I just don't know exactly how.
Speaker 5: They think that they're warm enough.
I don't think it will take a rocket scientist to
figure out that there's still probably going to be
spewing the regular B.S. But do you think it will
get worse or do you think it will get better?
Speaker 1: I think it may just evolve in terms
of the feel of it. I don't know, worse or better
kind of will depend on the political environment
and the cultural environment around it. But
you're already sort of seeing Fox News have to
figure out what space will they occupy
because, you know, the fake scandals
they've been concocting about Jill and Joe Biden
don't really love each other. It's an act. And,
you know, just kind of like weird mask stuff,
weird vaccine stuff. It's not none of it's
really catching that much. And so I think
Fox News is already kind of in a period of
self-examination to figure out what will work and
maybe a change. Now, remember, Rupert Murdoch's
not really handling the day to day anyway. And
so Rupert Murdoch being gone to use your term.
It's not clear to me that it will necessarily
change anything because you have other people
that are managing the day to day.
Speaker 5:
OK, and then my second question is, I know you've
talked about you don't think that Trump is going
to be charged. I agree with you. I don't think he
is either. But what do you think about Matt Gates?
Speaker 1: I think that if you give me an even
odds bet, just will he be charged or won't he?
I'm taking the yes, he will be charged, but it's
not like I feel super strong about it. I think
it's like 60-40 that Gates gets charged.
Speaker 5: Do you think that he would,
like, lose his position or anything?
Speaker 1: Well, there are rules in the House
of Representatives about that, and I believe that
if I'd have to review it. But if you're charged
with a felony, I think you are automatically
off of committees. But I don't know that
you have to resign unless you're you're proven
guilty. So I don't know about that. I'd have to
it would depend on what the charges are, I think.
Speaker 5: OK, yeah,
Speaker 1: thanks a lot. All right, my pleasure.
Great questions. Great to hear from you.
Let's hear from a few other people. Let's go to
oh, I need to speak to Joshua
from Portugal. I have questions.
Joshua from Portugal. You're on the air.
Speaker 6: Hello, Matt. It is an act of David
and sorry. It's an honor to speak with you.
Speaker 1: It's PI, Matt, Pat and David.
Everybody's here.
Speaker 6:
Sorry, sorry, I was I just didn't think I'd get
called on. I thank you for. Thank you for that.
Speaker 1: Listen, I have a question
for you. Are you in Portugal?
Speaker 6: Yes, I live here, OK? Portuguese.
Speaker 1: I have been following the travel
restrictions in Portugal very closely.
I was considering going to the Azores.
What I'm trying to silence what I'm trying to
understand is it looks like you can go to the
Azores with a negative test regardless of what the
rules are in mainland Portugal. Is that true or do
I have to wait for the mainland to open?
Speaker 6: I don't this I think I
haven't checked, but I believe the restrictions
are loosening up. But I still think you do need a
negative test if you are. Yes. You still
need the negative tips if you're going to
the Azores Islands, because it's an island
is more isolated than the rest of Portugal.
Speaker 1: But I would be allowed
to go to the Azores. You're saying
you're beautiful on just on your say. So I'm
going to book a ticket right after the show.
Speaker 6: I'm happy. Can I ask
you a quick question, please?
Speaker 1: I'm here at your service.
Speaker 6: I thank you. I'm David. I
was wondering, like, I don't like something. Is
it like do you see politically wise? Do you see
yourselves as a social Democrat or socialist?
Because I would I am very curious on that.
Speaker 1: Social Democrat, Social Democrat,
social. Yes. Which is that the Northern European
version of capitalism. Those are my views.
Speaker 6: OK, well, it's technically a more
European view of capitalism, social democracy,
Speaker 1: European, northern European. OK,
yes, sure.
Speaker 6: I mean,
it's just like because I live in as
you I guess I live in Europe and I.
I, I get a lot of headaches when people
call me a communist from the states,
despite the fact that I'm not a communist.
Right. Like, do you get that a lot as well
from other people? That I do. You a communist?
Speaker 1: I do. I get communist. I get socialist.
I get Zionist, I get authoritarian
fascist. I get all of these things.
I'm just the social Democrat. That's all.
Speaker 6: I know. I know. But I it's just
like it's frustrating when I hear it because it's
just not every American. But a lot of Americans
just don't seem to get the difference between
the groups. It is you're completely correct.
Speaker 1: It is frustrating. And Americans
don't seem to get it. And part of why they
don't get it is they've been fed lies from
Republicans about what it means to be socialist.
Speaker 6: Mm hmm. But yes, it's just the I
and it's in it. And they act like and they
always use that insult to me. Like the way you
just say they say socialist to me, like, yeah,
I don't I can never understand why they call me
that. And I understand that the states it's a
slur there to call someone a socialist. But to
me you're just miss I don't I don't like labels
and all that. But the way. But it does help you.
Speaker 1: It's like it's it's like saying, oh,
you're a Keynesian and making it an insult rather
than just a description of your economic beliefs.
Speaker 6: That's very true. And again, it gets
me frustrated. But I am sorry, but I thank you
very much. I hope I do hope you enjoy your trip
to the Azores. David and I, I've not been there,
but they are very beautiful islands. I hope
Speaker 1: it happens. And I so appreciate the
phone call. It's been a perfect phone call.
Speaker 6: Thank you. I appreciate
Speaker 1: it. There's Joshua from Portugal.
Listen, if you're holding to talk to me right now,
I'm begging you, don't hang up because we're
taking a very quick break. It'll feel like almost
nothing if you're holding. And then I'm going
right back to the Dischord Lines momentarily.